actually i always wanted to ask you like
going back to the monkey brain thing
like your opinion on gameplay
and we've had a few comments about this
yeah why don't you like fighting games
that is that's probably all for you the
game genre
that would like on in theory yeah appeal
to you the most there's no
story it's probably like the one type of
video game that i've just
never enjoyed playing like why is that
i've no i think is like the difficulty
curve is insanely high
and i feel that like i don't want to sit
there and have to research combos
because sure when i pull one off i'm
like cool that animation was
fine i guess you know i just don't feel
like i care
enough about like to learn these combos
whereas in a game like
i don't know like a first person shooter
it's so intuitive that like
it's just one bite right and like yeah
it is very
anyone can figure it out yeah but it's
that one simple mechanic that you keep
mastering and you keep getting better
and better and so it's kind of like
i've noticed that i really only enjoy
games where it's a easy to learn hard to
master type of thing
and fighting game is just hard to learn
even harder i feel finding games are
easy to learn
no stuff smash maybe yeah smash i think
it's fun
yeah i really enjoy smash is fun because
i feel that
it's just i don't know it's it's not
like [ __ ] tekken where i have to
worry about like the frames and the
spacing and stuff i don't know i know i
mean like people wouldn't smash worry
about that yeah
when you get so high but smash is a
casual game there i said it um
[Music]
i love watching smash competitive but
for me it's a party game right oh yeah
but that's the great thing about smash
right is that
really fun to watch as a party game but
it's also a really fun process yeah yeah
because the thing that's really hard
about fighting games is that
it's hardly ever a party game right
because whenever you are at a party and
people are playing fighting games
there's always that guy
or two guys you know you know who you
are you
you see people put on like smash or
tekken and you're like because they
never they
never leave that [ __ ] couch they will
never leave it if they need to piss
they're not going they won't
wait till they get home fighting games
don't wait like this is what they've
trained
like their entire life for like okay let
me let me let me smash the noobs
yeah yeah let me smash all the people at
this party and then they need to find
other people like them to like continue
on this path that they've put themselves
on
the same people who rock up to an anime
convention just with their like uh
the gamepad and they're like i know
where i'm spending this yes
there's no question about where i'm
spending these three days point me to
the room with the the wii u's
yeah because i feel like with fighting
games it's
yeah it's i i i i
enjoy watching fighting games more than
i i enjoy playing them yeah because
you get you get to a point where you're
just smashing buttons you're like i kind
of get it and then you go online or
something
and then you just get destroyed yeah
there is there is like the difficulty
curve as you said is just
casual but to be the difference between
a beginner and a casual is like
so [ __ ] massive oh it's huge you know
because you you go from button mashing
to having to learn like basic theory of
fighting games and basic combos and the
difference between that counting frames
yeah yeah and like different stuff the
difference between the beginner and the
casual is so
[ __ ] like okay for example right like
in a game of overwatch right
a a pro can be killed by someone who is
absolutely garbage at the game like it's
very plausible that
he could do that right but in a fighting
game the [ __ ] pros
never gonna lose it's not gonna happen i
think that that element of like all
right well
if i just play better most of the time
i'll always win right which is like it's
because in fighting games there's no
element of chance
yeah anyway like especially if you're at
a pro level because they just know
like what's coming and i think that's
kind of fun and that's the kind of stuff
that really
drives me into like overdrive of wanting
to learn something is that like
i had a chance of beating that guy and i
could have done it if i just keep
practicing i'll easily get it right then
i keep going
and that's how i got into league so then
maybe if you just gave that a go with
like like street fighter or like mortal
kombat
i reckon if you learn one fighting game
you'll be i gotta be honest which is why
i don't want to because i'm already
trying to learn like japanese last thing
i need
last thing i need is something else
taking over my [ __ ] life fair enough
it's like fighting games people i know
who like fighting games super chill but
their life is fighting games like they
don't talk about anything else like
they're like yeah
oh you had a nice day oh that's cool i
had a nice day learning the smash combos
like it's like it's like what like
they'll bring it up when it's not even
in the conversation yeah
yeah yeah i love leonardo dicaprio by
the way sorry [ __ ] it
oh that's what it sounds like sometimes
it's just horrible
he's like leonardo dicaprio somehow
turned into smash and it's like what the
[ __ ] that's
my shame the way i'd smash my combos
it's like what
what strike stop i will say like from
from the outside looking in the fighting
game community looks like one of the
funnest communities to be in
i love the trash talking the trash
talking is so good and it looks so good
league of legends they they ban that
[ __ ] i'm like dude i love trash
i love trash talking in video games i
think it's so fun
maybe it's because like the trash
talking in like some of those
communities just go a little bit too far
maybe i mean league of legends is not
true it's like i'm going to kill you in
your family yeah it's like a legit
threat sometimes but
i reserve the right to just type to
someone you're bad like i think that's
come on someone can do it to me i won't
mind it won't ruin my day i'm not in a
sense that's one of the worst ways to
trash talk right if you're just someone
just typed in
you are bad yeah chad lowercases like
how dare you it's like the worst type of
insult